بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم الحمد لله والصلاه
والسلام على رسول الله واشهد ان لا اله
الا الله وحده لا شريك له واشهد ان محمدا
عبده
ورسوله اللهم صل على محمد وعلى ال محمد
كما صليت على ابراهيم وعلى ال ابراهيم انك
حميد مجيد اللهم بارك على محمد وعلى ال
محمد كما باركت على ابراهيم وعلى ال اب
ابراهيم في العالمين انك حميد مجيد اما
بعد فالتفسير
موصول
حول ايات سوره
الرعد وقد وصلنا فيها الى
الايه ال9 والعش الايه وال
وهذا اخر لقاء من هذا العام اسال الله
تعالى ان
يتقبل منا
اجمعين
وان
يبلغنا الرمضان القادم باذن الله وان
يجعله خيرا مما اخذ
منا ك سوره
الرعد
ن
2 باذن الله يقول تعالى الذين
امنوا وعملوا الصالحات طوب لهم وحسن
ماب كذلك ارسلناك في امه قد خلت من قبلها
امم لتتل عليهم الذي اوحينا اليك وهم
يكفرون
بالرحمن قل هو ربي لا اله الا الا هو عليه
توكلت واليه
متاب ولو ان قرانا سيرت به الجبال او قطعت
به الارض او كلم به الموتى بل لله الامر
جميعا افلم يياس الذين امنوا ان لو يشاء
الله لهدى الناس جميعا ولا يزال الذين
كفروا تصيبهم بما صنعوا قارعه او تحل
قريبا من دارهم حتى ياتي وعد الله
ان الله لا يخلف
الميعاد قوله تعالى الذين امنوا وعملوا
الصالحات
هذا قد يكون من اوصاف من
اناب لان الله
تعالى
يقول ويقول الذين كفروا لولا انزل عليه
ايه من ربه
قل ان الله يضل من يشاء ويهدي اليه من
اناب من اناب الذين امنوا وتطمئن قلوبهم
بذكر الله الا بذكر الله تطمئن القلوب
الذين امنوا فاما ان
يكون
استئنافا يعني جمله
جديده او
يكون بدل اوص فه او الى غير ذلك من
التوابع
المعروفه يعني باختصار الكلام يكون من
صفات من
اوصاف من
اناب الذين ينيبونه
ربهم من اناب يعني رجع الى الله واقبل
عليه
بكنهه
وظاهره يقول تعالى ال الذين امنوا وعملوا
الصالحات من اناب الذين امنوا وعملوا
الصالحات طوبى لهم طوبى
هنا فهو مصدر
الطيب يعني كل طيب فهو
لهم وقال بعض
السلف رضي الله
عنهم ان طوبه
اسم لشجره في
الجنه ظلها كذا
وكذا
و عرضها كذا وكذا الى اخره وهذا الكلام
صحيح
ماخوذ من كلام النبي صلى الله عليه
وسلم الا ان في الجنه كذا وكذا وهي التي
تسمى بسدره
المنتهى في
سوره
النجم واسمها
طوب
لكن هل هذا
منتهى الطيب الذي يكون له هذا من الطيب
وليس هو كل
الطيب مثل
الكوثر يقول تعالى انا اعطيناك
الكوثر ما هو الكوثر الكوثر
لغه هو على وزن
فوع من الكثره الشيء
الكثير
جدا وكل ما عظم
خطره او خيره او شانه فان العرب يجعلونه
على
وزن
فوع ف
الكوثر على هذا الوزن للدلاله على
المبالغه وهو من
الكثره يعني اعطيناك الكثير الكثير
الكثير وقال بعض
الصحابه الكوثر اسم لنهر في
الجنه بل جاء هذا في حديث انس بن مالك في
صحيح مسلم ان النبي صلى الله عليه
وسلم قال ذلك
بنفسه قال او انزلت
علي
ا
سوره وقراها على الصحابه من حوله ثم
قال
الكوثر نهر في الجنه
واخذ يطنب في اوصاف
الكوثر لكن هل هذا منتهى الكوثر الذي
اعطاه الله هذا من الكوثر هذا من ال كثره
الخير العظيم الجم الذي اعطاه الله سبحانه
وتعالى فهذا يكون النهر الذي في الجنه
وزياده لانه
كوثر ما قال انا اعطيناك كثيرا بل قال انا
اعطيناك الكوثر
بل ولا قال الكثره قال
الكوثر وكذلك هنا الذين امنوا وعملوا
الصالحات طوبى
لهم طوبى
لهم وهذه الشجره العظيمه الطيبه التي هي
منتهى الطيب ومنتهى
الرحمه التي جعلها الله سبحانه وتعالى
لعباده الصالحين لجيرانه لاهله
هذه شجره
طوبه فهي من الطيب
والطيب
الذي اعطى الله سبحانه
وتعالى عباده
الصالحين ولكن هي ليست منتهى الطيب الذي
اعد الله لعباده
الصالحين بل هي من اصناف الطيب يقول تعالى
طوبى
وحسن
ماب الماب هو
المرجع والله عز وجل يصف الجنه بالماب
للصالحين اي بالمرجع للصالحين لان الجنه
اصلا
خلقت ل عباد الله الصالحين من بني ادم
منها اخرج ادم ابوه
عليه
السلام وكان
الهدف ومن اجل
خلقنا عباده الله سبحانه وتعالى والرجوع
في جوار
الله يقول تعالى وحسن
ماب كذلك
ارسلناك
كذلك يعني مثل ما ارسلنا الانبياء من قبلك
الذين سلف ذكر
كذلك
ارسلناك او يكون جوابا لقولهم وقالوا لولا
انزل عليه ايه من ربه كذلك
ارسلناك في امه قد خت من قبلها امم لتتلو
عليهم الذي اوحينا
اليك وهم يكفرون
بالرحمن او حين يقول ارسلناك في
امه الارسال
هنا بمعنى ان النبي صلى الله عليه
وسلم مرسل الى قوم مخالفون لهم في اصل
الدين فهم يكفرون بالله ويعبدون
الاصنام هم يؤمنون بوجود الله ويؤمنون
بكثير من اوصاف الله الا انهم
يشركون
بالله وفي عباده الله غيره
معه وهذا هو الكفر يقول تعالى كذلك
ارسلناك في
امه
الامه المقصود
منها هنا في هذا السياق كل من جاء بعد
رساله النبي محمد صلى الله عليه وسلم الى
قيام
الساعه الى لا ان يرث الله الارض ومن
عليها
فهذا امه امه النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم
هذه
الامه
يقول قد خلت من قبلها
امم وفي بعض الروايات ان هذه الامم عددها
70 هذه
الامه
السبعون وهي اخر
امه
وهل يعني ذلك ان الامم فقط 70 ولا اكثر
الله
اعلم اذا نظرنا الى عدد الرسل لمن يصحح
هذه الروايه وهي روايه عند الامام
احمد ان النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم سئل كم
عدد
الرسل فقال
315 جعل عددهم
رسولا
و هذه روايه اختلف الحفاظ
في تصحيحها
وتضعيفها وان كان الظاهر انها روايه صحيحه
وتلقاها العلماء
بالقبول وفيها
زياده وهذه الزياده زاد السائل
فقال والانبياء
فذكر النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم 120 ال
نبي هذا يدل على ان الانبياء
والرسل ليس كل نبي يكون رسولا وليس كل
رسول هذا هذا يدل على ان ثم فرقا بين
النبي
والرسول والذي عليه اكثر
العلماء من السلف
والخلف ان كل رسول نبي وليس كل نبي رسول
يعني الرسول نبي واكثر
وزياده وكل
رسول له
كتاب يعني
شريعه كل رسول له
شريعه لقد ارسلنا رسلنا
بالبينات
وانزلنا معهم الكتاب
والميزان الكتاب بمعنى الوحي المستقل لهذا
الرسول فاذا نظرنا الى ذلك قلنا
315 رسول
كل رسول له
كتاب الا اذا كان
في كتب مشتركه او رسل مشتركين في رساله
واحده مثل ما كان مع قوم في سوره ياسين
مثلا فعززنا
بثالث يعني قوينا بثالث هذول جاؤوا الى
قوم الى قوم
كفار رافضين ل للدين وعباده الله
وحده ومن اجل ذلك قتلوا ف هذا يدل على ان
الرسل قد يكون في اكثر من رسول لنفس الامه
موسى وهارون عليهما الصلاه
والسلام فقولا انا رسولا ربك
رسولا
ف لو نظرنا الى ذلك هل معنى 70 وهذه هذا
الرقم
في الصحيح في صحيح البخاري هل هذا الرقم
امه بمعنى الكثير من الامم ونحن اخر امه
ولا 70 هنا على معناه الحقيقي يعني 70 هذه
رقم
70 خلاف بين العلماء والظاهر انه ما في
مانع انه يكون فعلا 70 70 امه
مستقله وكل
امه تدعى يوم القيامه الى
كتابها وتحت لواء
رسولها وهذه الامه هي امجد الامم واعظم
الامم واكثر الامم واخلص الامم واعلم
الامم واكثرها شهداء واكثرها علما واكثرها
علماء لانها امه محمد صلى الله عليه وسلم
يقول قد خلت من قبلها امم لتتلو عليهم
الذي اوحينا
اليك
ف
ال
الرساله
تتضمن ان يتلو النبي صلى الله عليه
وسلم الذي اوحي اليه من الله يعني
القران وهذا يدل على ماذا على ان اكثر
القران مفهوم
واضح صحيح في بعض
الاشياء لا يعلمها الا العلماء لانها
تحتاج الى لان المقصود منها مقصد شرعي
يعني واقيموا الصلاه كم صلاه
في اي ساعه كل صلاه كيف
هي ها ركوع واحد وها سجود وهكذا
هذا معنى شرعي يحتاج الى النبي صلى الله
عليه وسلم يوضح هذه الاشياء لكن
عامه الفاظ القران
مفهومه سليقه
للعرب الذين ارسل فيهم النبي صلى الله
عليه
وسلم لذلك الانسان لما يرجع مثلا الى كتب
الحديث ينظر
الى كتب
الحديث التفاسير التي
جاءت عن النبي صلى الله عليه
وسلم بالنسبه
للايات قليله
جدا احديث التفسير قلي جدا احاديث التفسير
بمعنى بالمعنى الظاهر يعني يقول الرسول
صلى الله عليه وسلم هذه الايه معناها
هيك هذا
شيء هذا شيء يعني تحصيل
حاصل في اغلب احوال الصحابه رضي الله عنهم
بل
والكفار لانهم يفهمون هذا الكتاب بلغه
لغتهم وهذا هو الاصل الاصل ان القران
مفهوم واذا تابعت كتب التفسير من اولها
الى
اخرها تلاقي انه كتب
التفسير كانت في البدايه لم احاديث عن
النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم يذكر بعض
الالفاظ ثم
بعض الروايات
عن المتخصصين من الصحابه مثل ابن عباس
وابن مسعود وعلي بن ابي طالب وعبد الله بن
عمرو بن العاص وابي موسى الاشعري
وغيرهم ممن له شان في
التفسير بعدين تنتقل الى
طبقه التابعين تجد التفسير
تضخم صار اكثر لما بنتابع هذه المدارس
مدرسه ابن عباس له طلاب ابن مسعود له طلاب
وهلم جره بصير التفسير ايش اكثر لكن مازال
قليلا بالنسبه
للمتاخرين
تستمر
وتلاحظ التوسع لدوله
المسلمين ودخولهم في المناطق
الاعجميه تلاقي كلما دخلوا
في كل ما توسعت هذه الدوله
الاسلاميه
ودخل الناس افواجا في دين الله من الاعاجم
تجد ماذا يزداد التفسير وعلماء التفسير
يوضحون ويفصلون ويزيد تفصيلهم حتى اجا ابن
جرير الطبري كتابه كبير ولسه حاب هو يكبره
اكثر
لكن طلابه ما لم يقووا على
ذلك بعدين تنتقل حتى زماننا
هذا الان تجد
التفسير يعني حبه
حبه كل حرف لازم يفصل لماذا لبعد الناس عن
اللسان العربي والا فالاصل ان القران واضح
الله وصف القران وضوح بانه
مبين يعني بين في نفسه مبين لغيره وقليل
جدا يعني ما اجى
حدا من كفار قريش وقالوا والله احنا سمعنا
القران مش فاهمين شيء منه لا هم يفهمون
شيء قليل ما يفهمون مسائل غيبيه مسائل
تتوقف على فهم سابق والا ف القران واضح
بين لكن بين
لمن لمن استقام لسانه
سليقه وفهم ما كان يفهمه
العرب فلذلك بعد الناس ودخول و يعني دخول
العجمه على العرب هذا اللي
يسبب عدم الفهم في التفسير وهذا اللي سبب
اكثر تفاسير
التفاسير المبتدعه في
الدين من هذا
الباب هم ظنوا انهم فهموا القران ولكن
اخطاوا في فهمه للعجم التي طرات على
السنتهم من الفرس والروم
و هم يفكرون في لغه وينطقون في لغه اخرى
في لغه
العرب فعلى كل حال الاصل لتتلو عليهم الذي
اوحينا اليك مش لازم يزيد عليه شيء يتلوه
لذلك تجد كثير من خطب النبي صلى الله عليه
وسلم الخطبه كلها عباره عن قراءه سوره و
سورتين ولذلك قول النبي صلى الله عليه
وسلم ان قصر خطبه الرجل وطول قراءته مائن
على فقهه مئن يعني دليل على فقهه هذا يوم
الجمعه انه خطبته تكون قصيره وقراءته تكون
ايش طويله هذا يدل على
فقهه لكن الناس الان لا يفهمون لا يكادون
يفهمون
قوله كثير منهم الناس الان يحتاج الواحد
سنتين وثلاثه وخمسه وهو مولود عربي بين
العرب وتربى بينهم محتاج له خمس سنين يروح
يتعلم العربيه بس عشان يرجع يفهم شيء من
المعاني التي فهمها الصحابه رضي الله عنهم
سليقه اصبح هذا الشيء لا
يكفي اصبح الان كل
كلمه
فقوله تعالى لتتلو عليهم الذي اوحينا اليك
هذا يكفي لاقامه الحجه لذلك يقول ومن
بلغ يعني من بلغه هذا القران وصلته الحجه
هذا متى هذا في زمن النبي صلى الله عليه
وسلم يرسل الصحابي هو يقرا القران يرسله
الى عباره عن دول كامله يذهب يصلهم يقرا
عليهم القران يدخلون في الاسلام
بالمئات كيف هذه بتكون
معجزه ايه ايه الله الخالده لكن الان
يحتاج ال الى شغل كثير من الناس ومن
المسلمين حتى يفهموا القران ويفهموا شيئا
من المعاني التي فهمها احاد الناس في زمن
نزول الوحي يقول لتتلو عليهم الذي اوحينا
اليك وهم يكفرون
بالرحمن يعني الله يوحي اليه سبحانه يوحي
الى النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم هذا القران
من هنا وهم يكفرون بالرحمن من هنا وانظروا
الى احسان الله
سبحانه وانه لا احد اصبر على اذى سمعه من
الله كما قال النبي صلى الله عليه
وسلم قوله وهم يكفرون بالرحمن يعني بعباده
غيره سبحانه يعبدون غير
الرحمن فعباد تهم لغير الرحمن جعلهم
كافرين به وان كانوا يؤمنون
بوجوده وكذلك كانوا يكفرون بالصفات الخاصه
باسم
الرحمن الرحمن في لغه العرب على وزن
فعلان وهذا الوزن في لغه العرب يدل على
الكثره التي يصعب
تخيلها لذلك
يصفون
الله سبحانه وتعالى
بالرحيم وهذه صيغه مبالغه برضه لكن
الرحمن كانوا يقولوا هذه درجه من
الرحمه حتى الله ليس له هذه
الرحمه يعني هم تصوروا في زمن الجاهليه ان
هذه الدرجه من
الرحمه يعني الرحمن
فعلان يدل على
المبالغه العظيمه في
الرحمه يقولون الله راحم ورحيم لكن رحمن
هذه درجه لا يتصور حتى الله رب العالمين
ان تكون له رحمه مما تقتضي هذه الكلمه
وهذا
الوزن فكانوا لا
يستعملون كلمه
رحمن لذلك جاء الرحمن من اسماء الله
الخاصه يعني يجوز مثلا يرحمك الله يجوز
مثلا تسمي واحد راحم ويجوز تسميه رحيم لا
يجوز له ان تسميه رحمن هذا لا
يجوز لان ثم اسماء من اسماء الله هي خاصه
به ليس لشيء ش من خلقه
نوع اشتراك في جنس هذه في جنس هذا هذه
التسميه فمثلا يقول تعالى قل ادعوا الله
او ادعوا الرحمن ايما تدعو فله الاسماء
الحسنى لان الله والرحمن هذه اسماء خاصه
بالله فالله عز وجل
انزل بسم الله الرحمن
الرحيم اول ما
نزل فوصف الله نفسه بانه الله
الرحمن هذه الدرجه من الرحمه التي تخطر
ببالكم هذه لا تعبر عن حقيقه رحمه الله
سبحانه فلذلك
انكر كثير منهم اسم الرحمن وقالوا ما نعرف
ما
الرحمن الا رحمن
اليمامه رحمن اليمامه كان مسيلمه مسمي
حاله رحمن
اليمامه ف ما تجد نادر جدا تجد حدا اسمه
عبد الرحمن في
زمن
الجاهليه في كل كتب الرجال في تقريبا
اثنين ومختلف فيهم اذا كان فعلا اسمهم عبد
الرحمن لكن بعد الاسلام اكثر اسم عبد الله
وعبد الرحمن ومحمد هذه الاسماء التي
انتشرت حتى
اول اول
واحد او يعني من اوائل ما سمى النبي صلى
الله عليه
وسلم سمى عبد الرحمن
هو عبد الرحمن بن
عوف رضي الله عنه فعلى كل حال
الرحمن من له الرحمه الواسعه العظيمه
فالله عز
وجل هو يرسل خير الرسل بخير الكتب يتلو
عليهم الكتاب وهم يكفرون
بالرحمن قال تعالى قل هو
ربي يعني معبودي
وخالقي لا اله الا هو اي لا معبود بحق
الا عليه
توكلت
وحده واليه متاب واليه اتوب وارجع
وحده
وهذا يكفي
و والله اعلم وصلى الله وسلم على نبينا
محمد وعلى اله واصحابه اجمعين اسال الله
تعالى ان يتقبل منا اجمعين قيامنا وصيامنا
وصدقات نساله سبحانه وتعالى ان ينتصر
لاخواننا المجاهدين في كل مكان وفي غزه
وفلسطين خاصه اسال الله تعالى ان ينصرهم
نصرا مؤزرا اساله سبحانه وتعالى ان يعلمني
واياكم من كتابه ما جهلنا وان يذكرنا منه
ما نسينا وان يعلمنا الحكمه منه ومن يؤتى
الحكمه فقد اوتي خيرا كثيرا ونساله سبحانه
وتعالى ان يجعل القران العظيم ربيع قلوبنا
ونور صدورنا وجلاء احزاننا وذهاب همومنا
اللهم امين وصل اللهم وسلم على نبينا محمد
وعلى اله واصحابه اجمعين وجزاكم الله
خيرا ‏veres number 29 and
30 chapter
number الله سبحانه
وتعالى
in and those who disb they say if
only if only a
mir محمد صل عليه وسلم ‏if only he could
produce for us a mirle to prove that he
is really a prophet we would believe in
him of
course this
is a very dishonest disingenuous
representation
tru صلى الله عليه
وسلم
miracles
however he didn't necess bring
‏come a prophet do this do that if
really a prophet have your lord do this
for us or do
that
grand عليه
الصلام
‏tell him to the day of judgment from
right now tell him to anil us
with a rainstorm
of stones kill us all tell him to
destroy us the previous nations
tell us tell him or things that are
really
inappropriate and articulate the degree
of
hu such as
‏only the angels come stand all them in
front us we in you if you have a
proprietary
staircase that takes you directly into
the heavens and you can go up and down
whenever you want and we can go in and
out whenever we
want if you do that may believe you
things
‏outrageous and so he would bring he
would obviously not respond to these
requests they would say well he hasn't
produced for us this far evidence he
produc many evidences just not the
evidences that you had
requested
وعى us
miracle
say indeed
الله he ches and he guid to him those
who bese him those who turn to allah he
guid those
people
so
‏really important to us now is how do
people end up in paradise he says and he
guid to
him those who turn to him
wholehearted then he goes and describes
these individuals he says those who
believe and their
hearts قران
‏indeed it is by the of
doqu الله سبحانه وتالى in
next those who believe and work
righteous deed for them is for them is
abundance of
good and the best of
ab he
‏we have you just as we have
seng and props before you we have sent
you to a
nation which nations have
pred in order that you may recite upon
them that which we have raled to
you
and
paric
concurrently
الرحمن الله سبحانه
وتعالى things
number
heent as we have those who preceded you
prophets meaning he is not in any way
unique in
that he fits
the
‏of prop that hased
him second of
all his primary responsibility is toite
that which allah has revealed to him
upon the
people what's meant here by recite is to
recite and to follow to
implement that which we
have revealed to
you and
‏iric الله سبحانه
وتالى
بك صلى الله عليه
وسلم
‏as
bel
قران toit the criteria of a
beli yes person believes in the
existence
of
الله سبحانه وتالى ex and he believe in
attribut of الله as described by himself
and his messenger and he must as well
affirm worship only for allah alone
without any partners he says say to them
he instructing the prophet عليه وسلم my
n ‏and alone i have put my trust and he
and him alone is my
repentance so this is where we have
reached in our unfortunately we were
unable to get through the entirety of
chapter end of i
expect ask الله سبحانه وت to accept our
in mon and
to place many more
رض والله اعلم وصلى الله وسلم على نبينا
محمد وعلى اله واصحابه اجمعين والحمد لله
رب العالمين وجزاكم الله
خي